That's it man I'm doing great uh I've
been a fan of your work for a long time
it's cool to talk with you
um
if you if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why Boom the first thing wow that's
a hard one uh
uh I don't know Up in Smoke
I guess you know to to let them know
what they're in for
sure I you know I I don't know if you
get one of the things about the movies
you made uh back then
um I really do think that that brought a
lot of like uh it's it's crazy how far
it's come from marijuana in the late 70s
early 80s to the way it is today and I
think that that your films helped sort
of push the conversation or do you think
so oh yeah I'd absolutely do you know we
were always at on in some court is
criticized because we're promoting
marijuana and we said at some point you
know what if we're right what if
marijuana is good for you and has
medicinal properties and can help people
you know well who's laughing now oh 100
um uh were you surprised at the
popularity of those films back then no I
wasn't I was I was surprised I would
have been surprised if they weren't
popular because us we had been uh had
big big popular records and won Grammys
and and gold records and all those
things and and uh and so I knew and we
had been performing sold out concerts
everywhere so I knew that we had an
audience because I'd been looking across
the footlight throws so I knew that uh
it was going to have some success it had
much more success than I anticipated and
became worldwide that's really the
difference between doing records and
concerts and and movies because they can
neither dub or or
subtitle your movies so you get but it
was always great when they uh when they
just subtitled them
because you could hear our voices you
directed born in East L.A back in 86 87.
um how how and that I think that's the
last time you directed a feature how
close did you come to directing
something else after that you know
not close because I really like this is
a lot of work you know me being the
actor and writer and director and
producer at the same time I I don't know
if I want to do this anymore and then
you you spend a lot of time developing
as a director project then they get to
the and then no they say no uh wait a
minute I just spent three years doing
this
you know so I don't I wasn't I like
directing but you know it's a lot of
work and I and so I decided to
concentrate on acting I understand
completely jumping into why I get to
talk to you
um you've worked with Woody before I
believe you did a play with him a fam
Shepard play what was it like getting to
you know work with him again
um uh because he seems like he'd be
really fun scene partner he is a fun
scene partner and that's kind of really
the initial push to do this film uh I
was gonna I knew Woody well again
because we had worked together so this
is going to be fun this could add that
after having read the script I could
really see ourselves in these roles and
this is going to be fun and this is
going to be I think it's going to be a
very eye-opening experience which it
turned out to be I've seen I've been on
set watching Woody work uh I was on the
set of the Zombieland movie and a few
other things and he to me it it seems
like every take he does something
slightly different yeah
um so what is it like working with
someone who really is in the moment and
willing to just try things oh it's
perfect perfect because he works
improvisationally not making up the
dialogue but but and the Rhythm at which
he performs the piece and so it's improv
and I'm an improv actor myself so so we
got along really well because we know
how to listen listen to each other and
that comes out of that process you know
sometimes you can say more by not saying
anything what was your experience
working with the friends and
non-professional actors you know that
was my greatest
I'm not concerned but question can first
of all can these kids play ball because
that's going to be apparent if they can
and uh and how you know they're
unprofessional actors uh you know they
were they were an experience so how's
that going to work it worked great in
both ends because first of all they
could play ball and that was readily
apparent and then they had so many other
interests outside of outside of uh
either playing ball you know like one
kid spoke seven languages uh the other
kids you know could dance really really
really well that even though they had
physical disabilities and they were like
every day was a new surprise so that it
was always fun and that way I'm always
amazed when I hear from
when someone could speak more than one
language because I could barely speak
English
you know I'm very I'm so impressed
um
but we'll talk a little bit about
working with Bobby Fairley because I'm a
big fan of his work especially when he's
worked with his brother he's in so many
movies that I think are so funny me too
I'm a big fairly Brothers fan you know I
just I just they have a they have
conceits in their movie that are just so
hilarious uh and they and they they make
them work so I was really interested you
know eager to work with Bobby although
it wasn't a fairly Brothers movie but it
was going to be Bobby as soy and and it
wasn't straight out comedy you know this
was going to be something else it's
gonna be an uplift team film it was a
big romance in in the middle of it it
was surprising and surprise surprisingly
well uh the those two together Caitlyn
and Woody together were really good and
so uh it's all surprises in this movie
you know so I think the audience is
going to be well rewarded if they go to
see it like seven times in a row exactly
spend the day in that theater just going
yeah I get out of the the snow and go in
there speaking of Woody and Caitlin um I
actually thought they were fantastic
together me too I totally bought into
their chemistry yeah absolutely I was it
was really the heart of the movie for me
you know they're watching this distance
this romance unfold and the
complications that it comes with I love
learning about the behind the scenes
making movies TV shows is there anything
that you think might surprise audiences
to learn about the actual making of
Champions well that we endured the cold
it was like freeze in there we shot in
in Winnipeg and it was just so cold uh
that
that with non-professional actors that
they they could
really rise to the occasion it was
amazing it was amazing you know they
weren't doing like Shakespeare or Hamlet
but they were non-professional actors
you know those like acting some as
asking somebody to be really good in
figure skating when they've never put on
a pair of figure skates before so on
that note I need to wrap with you I'm
just gonna say again fan of your work
thank you for giving me your time hope
the film's a huge yet thank you very
much man thanks for coming and seeing
the film appreciate it cool have a great
day